не знаєш коли ти втратиш близьку до себе
людину росіяни як нам зараз стало відомо
роблять мільйон в місяць таких пвідронів
я на сегодняшний день своими мощностями
могу собирать не меньше 50 единиц в день
друзі Всіх вітаю бачите трошечки трясе в
дорозі ну такі вони дороги на Донеччині
бачите який у нас крутий водій і ми з
Марією іоновою їдемо до дружніх
підрозділів напередодні нового року 2014
року намагаємося
допомагати військовим підрозділам і з
багатьма героями дружимо з того часу і
це дуже важливо насправді пам'ятати якою
важкою ціною сьогодні бережеться
українська незалежність відвойовується
український суверенітет раді що от зараз
їдемо до наших друзів веземо такі
дефіцитні fpv дрони мавіки смаколики
іншу допомогу яка грілки що в нас там
іще грілки
ішки вітамінні
набори тривога знову от
тягни вашій хаті Привіт Привіт Дивися
все що ти просив акумулятор це не все що
він просив ну половина хорошо половина з
того що ти просив бачиш бачиш mavic
fpvдron до нього ще мають бути
акумулятори чи вони внутрі ні
акумулятори во окремо є молодці молодці
бутербродік ще зроблю з чим з
ікоркою в мо буде з сельцем але але то
гарно і скажу вам Чесно це дуже важливо
і в тому числі і для того аби
усвідомлювати і потребу наших збройних
сил України і
проблематику підрозділів і допомагати
військовим дуже важливо щоб всі
долучалися і продовжували підтриму ти
збройні сили України і кожного солдата
котрий перебуває на передовій підтримати
дронами чи цукеркою чи якимись іншими
словами добрими словами телефонним
дзвінком люди Дивіться це fpv Дрон
для нормальної роботи на місяць треба
хоча б 10 000 таки на місяць знаєте не з
кабінетів все-таки не в теорії А на
практиці розуміти які мають бути зміни
до законодавства аби збройні сили були і
захищені і ну мали все необхідне
забезпечення если у меня Дрон долетает
до цели Я вижу классную картинку То есть
я могу различить царапины грубо говоря
на танке это хороший Дрон І от скажу вам
Чесно не знаю де ці знамениті армія
Дронів тому що ці підрозділи які ми
регулярно відвідуємо а вони знаходяться
і на авдіївському напрямку на
бахмутському на Лимані ну ну є там
дефіцит і тепловізорів і Дронів і систем
ребів да і все це дуже і дуже потрібно
приротах ударных беспилотных
авиакомплексов создать мастерские Ага по
производству этих Дронов лучше чем мы не
сделает ни одна организация Дрон и он
полетит туда куда надо и он
действительно будет поражать цели це
важкий ліманський напрямок і пан
Геннадій він керує новоствореним
фактично підрозділом а безпілотників я
на сегодняшний день своими мощностями
могу собирать не меньше 50 единиц в день
Круто То есть если я там были бы тільки
материал да был бы материал я бы мог бы
взять на обеспечение какую-то ещё
бригаду а то две у которых нет таких
возможности и им передавать эти дроны
вот почему это за пароли я прекрасно
понимаю потому что стоимость дрона на
сегодняшний день 12 000 грн его
себестоимость а продают они нам их по 26
кошмар і найбільш неприємне те що
окупант Російська Федерація за цей рік
зробили дуже серйозний ривок росіяни як
нам зараз стало відомо роблять мільйон в
місяць таких півідронів А на жаль там
Російська Федерація обходить санкції і
вже там своє виробництво от Марія багато
дуже спілкується з нашими західними
партнерами і немає такої зустрічі і
розмови де б ми не говорили про
посилення санкцій через те що через
треті країни вона зараз посилює свой
військово-промисловий
комплекс знаєте ту дуже
важливо говорити не тільки про санкційну
політику з Ми з тими країнами які
допомагають напряму російськії Федерації
а дуже важливо проводити дипломатичні
зусилля що стосується вторинних санкцій
і це не тільки комплектуюч це все ж таки
логістичні маршрути Це ті страхові
компанії які рахує цей груз тобто є дуже
багато складових і щоб була така
загальна
система санкцій з нашими дру з нашими
партнерами і нам треба з кожною країною
окремо теж посилювати тиск
парламентарями з урядом з громадським
сектором суспільство доносити в те що
вони не можуть фінансувати військову
махіну Російської Федерації загроза є
для всього світу так само і для їх країн
на бахмутському напрямку всі ці 22
місяці знаходиться 10та бригада
едельвейсів із Степан Барна який ну з
перших днів повномасштабного вторгнення
на цьому напрямку степане дуже важкий
був рік для тебе особисто для твоєї
родини втратили нашуго побратима твого
брата коли ми говоримо про наших
побратимів котрі віддали життя за
Україну в цей час і в цьому році
усвідомлювати Головне щоб ця смерть була
недаремною щоб кожне життя здоров'я
втрачене нашими
бійцями воно давало перспективу всій
Україні треба розуміти що тут ми стоїмо
для того щоб Україна жила щоб вдома було
Різдво щоб діти
колядували сім'ї Створювалися і
одружувалися діти народжувалися друзі Ми
маємо незважаючи на те що війна
усвідомлювати що ми будуємо маємо
будувати потужну велику сильну Україну
турбуйтеся про тих хто в тилу турбуйтеся
про тих хто творить економіку не буде
сильного тилу не буде сильної армії ти
на Новій машині Ну ми приїжджали це не
нова машина
цена таж є Ну маю на увазі що в тебе
знаєш цього разу не правокермова машина
отже отже ну вперше ми не ці їдемо я так
розумію що це теж волонтерська правда це
так побратими друзі з шведи Свенська
бусарня організація передала нам дві
машини навіть за кордоном люди нас
підтримують тут шведи там поляки там
німці одним словом весь світ помагає Я
за це Дякую також Ну і Ми дякуємо всьому
світу і усвідомлюємо нашу
відповідальність поки наші найкращі
побратими більше 2 пося партійців
європейської солідарності сьогодні на
фронті і ну на найгаряче
напрямках ми маємо безумовно
продовжувати збирати для них дрони
тепловізори системи реб машини Ну все що
потрібно для того аби були забезпечені
підрозділи необхідним для війни і так
само посилювати антипутінську коаліцію і
наших партнерів за кордоном там теж в
тонусі тримати щоби все-таки зброї було
більше Цінуйте близьких бо особливо
Цінуйте тих хлопців котрі
бо скажу для з власного досвіду що не
знаєш коли ти втратиш близьку до себе
людину тому користайтеся нагодою завжди
дзвоніть
спілкуйтеся бажайте один одному добра і
все буде добре Слава Україні